idaho nearly 2 000 miles from the
southern border but the state is seeing
a massive spike in fentanyl overdoses
with 96 percent of the drugs trafficked
in the region coming from mexico fox and
friends enterprise reporter lawrence
jones just got back from idaho where he
got a first-hand look at what's going on
there good morning good morning guys
every state is a border state because
the drugs that are coming into the
country are affecting everyone in the
country i had the opportunity to talk to
the sheriff the governor there this is
what they had to say watch
we're going out into this area looks
nice and calm i can guarantee you there
are cartel
members
in this area we're going to this goes
all the way to california
this road right here yeah
drugs coming this way absolutely
absolutely there's been cars going back
for 18 wheelers could drift
be
in these vehicles
it could be in every one probable in
half of them our number one threat is
that border
because everything that's the gateway
that everything that's bad coming across
it ends up in america
96 of the law enforcement agencies
concur that the fentanyl and the meth
that are coming into idaho are sourced
in mexico how bad is it it's bad and
it's getting worse because it's getting
to be more and more abundant and it's
getting to be cheaper last year
over 90 thousand americans died from
drug overdoses and the two primary drugs
that they overdose on are fentanyl and
methamphetamine those drugs come from
one place and that's south of our border
just in the last year we had several
overdose deaths we had a homicide
directly tied to a drug deal that had
gone back it was a fentanyl drug deal it
happened 100 yards from my front door i
have had
the unfortunate task of having
conversations with
family members who have lost children
who have lost fathers who have lost
mothers the people that are
manufacturing this fentanyl that are
bringing this fentanyl across the border
and that are selling it absolutely know
that it kills people over 40 percent of
every pill
is a lethal dose
one grain of fentanyl that would fit on
the end of your pencil is enough to kill
you within the last three months i had
two officers where we process them into
the jail
working on the guy's wallet or his money
and bag and they opened the bag and both
men
went to the ground instantly just
dropped like that because
those are airborne particles we
administered narcan immediately and then
one officer had to go on a narcan iv
drip to save his life that's that's the
type of stuff that's coming across this
corner absolutely
every day that that's what our guys are
dealing with out there on the streets
every day we're in uh undisclosed
location right here
this is where your operations have the
narcotic yeah bus talk about how risky
it is i mean it's already risky yeah a
cop yeah but taking on the cartel yeah
these guys are at high risk every minute
of every day the federal government
always tends to
get out of their lane defending this
country is a is the role is the
designated role by the founders of this
country
to defend the defend the country and to
protect the borders are we losing that
fight right now oh absolutely no
question about it that's why
i was one of 25 governors that uh sent a
letter to the president saying uh this
this is a crisis we've got to address
this and what did the president say what
did his office well
i think the letter just went out last
week so
uh we're waiting for it for a reply i
met mr trump twice i was in the white
house twice meeting with him on these
issues he brought us to the table this
administration we have we have none of
that
not only do we not get invited to the
table there is no table because in their
eyes there's no problem everything that
you guys are doing currently
unfortunately is reactionary all
reactionary defensive absolutely and
it's a band-aid on the flowing artery
let's put a band-aid here the blood's
still flowing the drug problem
is not something that we can arrest our
way out we have to deal with the supply
side and that is
doing something about our borders are we
losing
the war right now
[Music]
without a doubt
law enforcement's in the battle to the
bitter end but america is losing the
battle we are losing this war at the
border we're losing this war in our
neighborhoods
such an impactful piece there lawrence
but the thing that stood out the most
was something we heard right at the very
beginning looking at all the cars coming
the trucks coming a half of them have
the bad stuff in them and that that's
shocking to me and 40 of the drugs that
people are taking right now
um is known to have phenol in it um so
kids
these aren't drug addicts these are kids
that are trying to go to parties and
they might want to experiment well that
experiment could kill them and they
don't know what they're taking right now
the most telling part of this piece was
him saying we cannot police our way out
of this everything that they're doing
right now is reactionary because until
they stop the pipeline which is the
border
there's not going to be any type of
compromise
on this issue and he said we're not
invited to the table there is no table
none whatsoever and i think when people
look at the border they say okay this is
just about the legal migrants it's not
just about it's the drugs it's a
trafficking that has happened it is an
entire criminal enterprise
thanks lawrence